really what was actually happened was
that I was modeling Mike after him yeah
but I thought that we just
coincidentally were the same yeah and
then um he looks Indian too
he actually looks way less he looks like
every Indian guy that ever existed
according to our fans yeah
[Music]
yeah all right this um this is a
question from one of our esteemed
patrons apple apple always got a lot of
good stuff
um at any point in your life did you
ever have
somebody that could be considered either
an arch nemesis or a rival of course who
is that my ex-friend Steve your
ex-friend Steve my ex-friend Steve would
try to see my girlfriend then I [__]
got revenge on him yeah you try to steal
your girlfriend you remember the musical
episode oh that one yeah that guy
[__] the one that was talking
[__] about you behind your back to her
but was he so he was understood on his
half as well that you were his friends
no no no no no no no I can't find out
when I gave him the phone call and told
him how does it feel with another shoes
on the other foot you son of a [__]
thought about it for months how long was
that rivalry I mean I I finished the
sucker in three months so not long Steve
was like it really wasn't much of a
rivalry it was more of a decimation it
was a yeah
it's easy to take out the little man
it's very easy
yeah did you ever have any any rivalries
for like fighting when you were starting
out or like even now like anybody that
you or even a ride he knocked out my
teammate twice that doesn't invited me
though with friends I know but still
it's nice but like a friendly ride why
would you knock out your friend that's
[__] up yeah why did you not got my
friend man hey dude I just read Twitter
and read it and like I think it's pretty
[__] up to knock out your friend
what do we need I don't need it no more
did you have any arrivals in the gym you
know sometimes like two people the same
weight class or whatever like you have
like no that's weird I know I have no
issues with anybody like ever it's weird
I know it sounds super made up but I
don't think no I believe it everyone
loves you though yeah everyone loves one
yeah
but then those are the people that get
hated on the most in secret really I
don't know anyone that doesn't like Ron
Ron you ever been in a restaurant and
like nobody's no waiters come for like
an hour
and you're just like
no it's uh
uh Ron probably only eats at all friends
restaurants
like literally everyone
supported me everyone loves raw is crazy
like I'll be like me and like Ron will
be training and I'm like oh you know
what I kind of want to get my car
wrapped he goes dude I know a guy yeah
I'll go and then I'm like uh I'll go
visit him and then he'll be like oh how
do you know whatever and I'm like oh I
and Ronnie was like oh you
you and awesome we're best friends
every single person I meet he's the
mayor of every room he's in dude exactly
like everyone loves Rod yeah and then we
went to go eat in Vegas
and then you ate under a [__] fake
Alias and then he's like he's like oh
don't worry I got we got some [__]
fancy ass Italian place and then because
he was like I don't know he said like
he's like uh oh this is a table of four
for Charles or some [__] what name did
you use uh Henry there's a table for
Henry and I looked at Ronald Mike
so I think Ron has a baller ass friend
that was like yo like just you can get
into anywhere get tables anywhere just
go under my name like for the last I
don't know how long I've known Ron maybe
like six seven years he's everyone loves
him it's crazy I believe it there's got
to be one guy that knows everyone loves
you and is like I hate that everyone
that guy what do you think it would be
is there anybody you can think of that
will like like [__] usually those people
are the ones that have competition with
you and you thought they were like your
friends yeah yeah Secrets I've had those
instead of rivalries where it's just
kind of like afterwards you're like man
you were competing with
me I wish I knew I would have competed I
would have gave you real competition but
just the fact that you're existing they
were fighting toward like stomping on
you but you're not it's effortless at
what period was that when someone was
like secretly competitive was that like
during the Parada yeah I mean throughout
life yeah there'll be instances of that
where people were just like I found out
later that they were competing against
me and I was like
on what and me and then I wish I knew
because then if if I like competition
right so if I knew then it's like let's
[__] go then [__] and then like but
that might be too much for them
sometimes I don't know I think for most
people it is like competition like that
like actual like knowing that uh It's
Gonna be Me versus you I think there's a
certain type of breed that like actually
want that smoke and then like have it
open about it but it's like that friend
of me jealousy [__] where they see you
doing good and then they're like oh I
can't wait till I'm better and I can
show them this and then they I think
they use that as motivation and I don't
know how harmful it is because like I
feel really bad could be really bad well
I never got into the whole thing where
like it's affected me because they were
trying to destroy me it's always been
like I think they just wanted to one-up
me so they had a secret com competition
every time I did well or whatever then
like and then like later I found out
like it's more like a game of ketchup
than it is competition but it was a it
was a one-sided rivalry yeah yeah and I
know other people will do that too yeah
yeah yeah I feel like I've had a
one-sided rivalry to where like when I
was first starting out in uh b-boy
tournaments and stuff there was a dude
that like I was a really big fan of This
Crew This Crew is called bam tribe it
was like the premier like Asian uh b-boy
crew of this area
and they had just all the coolest guys
were in it like just all people that you
could tell were individually popular
wherever the [__] they were coming from
uh like one dude had dreads like you
know like all the cool types of
different Filipino guys yeah it was like
you just mash them all together but it
was so underground and it still is to
this day but there was a dude that
looked like the counterpart of me at
least I imagined he did yeah and a lot
of the time I just imagined that oh
that's the guy that I need to beat
because like I imagine we had a similar
aesthetic he was levels above me I
imagine we had a similar Vibe and
everything but really what was actually
happened was that I was modeling my [__]
after him yeah but I thought that we
just coincidentally were the same yeah
and then um he looks Indian too
he actually looks way less he looks like
every Indian guy that ever existed of
corn door fans yeah
the Bollywood Superstar but uh So
eventually I never actually got to know
him but we would like if I had to battle
him in the bracket like he was super
like he would go super hard and I would
lose and then uh one day when I finally
won against him like it I hope that like
that was like a sign of like maybe I
earned his respect a little bit and then
I started talking to him and he's just
the coolest guy and I told him like
years later like we had like a lunch and
I just wanted to tell him like yo like I
might have looked like I was just
jocking your guy's crew but really like
my idea of Quest Crew was like a version
of your crew and he had no idea that
like he was an inspiration he thought
that I was just annoying like I was just
always on his ass like I was always
trying to take him out but it's like no
dude like I realized later in life I
wanted to be like you yeah and it was
like a really big moment and now that
I've beaten you I can tell you
I'll always think he's better not that I
have bested you in battle in combat and
you will cover the bill correct but
that's the thing that I always wanted to
say but I wanted to earn the right to
speak I was like I want to at least I
want to at least meet you at your level
for a moment I feel like that's lost
upon yeah like I don't think that I'm
better than him I just wanted to at
least get here eye level so I could be
like hey let me tell you the real [__]
and then I can drop back down and be
like did you use the move what's the
move the the move beat him the more you
jump on your [__] head yeah and spin
around
is that what B is that what best it is I
don't even
not not that round no no not that wrong
he'd even beat it dude but that was the
that was the uh that was actually the
first
I think it was the first competition
where I did do that but it was in the
bracket prior to him so he saw that and
even in the video of me doing that you
can see one of his friends like this is
so funny because like who would have
thought I would notice this [__] but in
like our [__] camcorder videos of all
our battles you can see that when I go
out he's still in the crowd watching the
battles and we like have the same
[__] hair and everything and his
friend across goes like this he points
at me and goes
to say that I look like him and then and
then that guy goes to his friend goes
because it's like I'm annoying to him I
always [__] look like the guy but I
am in my head I built this scenario that
like oh we just like happened to look
the same it's like no I was [__]
looking like well you you do that when
you're younger [__] psychopath dude I
think that Ryan's wild is maybe an
understatement yeah
Ryan was Michael Jordan dude yeah
because I would study my footage
footage and where like he knows that
people are always like but you're
watching the [__] you're not saying
the footage you're watching the crowd
yeah yeah dude Ryan's like and that's
when I took that person yeah we would do
that to make sure that like that certain
like if people were feeling what we did
then we would know like oh it's cool
because like you could see someone go
and we go oh it got acknowledged the
thing you did the details yeah but then
I noticed that I was like hey there's a
whole side conversation right here
yeah you did it in a different time you
you did the head move ment that day I
did yeah you think he got in his head
doing that [__] his Camp is like the
moves are too good we can't yeah I think
you noticed that I I did improve and he
told me that I did get better but it's
cool because we developed like he he's a
generation above me and now like we we
developed like a relationship of like
hey man like like he looks at me like
one of the people that rightfully does
credit
his crew which really you can't even
it's hard to find you can't Google these
guys no no no you buried him so deep
under the Earth that you have to [__]
use excavator and [__]
you have to go to the library and pull
out old documents no they just they just
you gotta hire [__] archaeologists
and [__] they I think there's the crew
yeah I think it's a crew
this is maybe the symbol they use no
it's not never mind we have to go deeper
I think it's really like uh like they
put it down more than Quest did I think
but there's just no record
it's very everything
that is a full burial dude that's a that
was a full that is a full-fledged
beautiful that's that's a fossil dude
dude that is like the Undertaker versus
Mankind through four tables
YouTube so far except imagine nobody
remembers Mankind's name yeah whoa I
don't live in that one wow Jesus who's
Mankind's brother wait big Foley is
mankind yeah he doesn't have a brother
does he have a brother no dude
Kane is undercut
Kane actually showed his face that one
time you should be embarrassed you want
to delete he showed his face that whole
time where he ran for mayor dude oh yeah
outside of wrestling you have a future
in that too just a gut feeling
don't make any Rivals along the way
you didn't you didn't have a rival when
you were like doing
I was kind of I think I was what about
at the gym because I know there's like
what your old gym I had like friends
there's some trainers that are kind of
annoying too right you're like
oh yeah but people trying to poach
clients and [__] yeah potentially but it
was more of like
I don't want to say that I had an
arrival it was more of like friendly
competition in the way of like man I
want to be where that dude's at oh like
healthy competition yeah like like I
want to strive for for what that oh
that's cool yeah but then those people
eventually became my friends like they
it was just more of like okay because I
would like pick their brain and how they
do things and I thought it was really
interesting like I really like learning
about the process that way right like
even picking your brain about stuff I'm
like that's [__] tight you're right
though not Rivals but like can you
imagine if this was a rivalry but a
little bit yeah a little bit I can see
it actually yeah actually no rivals on
dude
dude that's [__] up man no but I'm not
really I don't think I've uh had
anything like that no arch nemesis that
you're aware of sometimes don't you wish
you did because like yeah you know if
you were Coke and you had a Pepsi yeah
it just it would push you forward it
does yeah it only does its metal bro it
helps it helps your business too yeah
yeah I think for a while though I was
afraid of competition in a lot of ways
because I was afraid of like failing but
you're competitive [__] you got
into fighting
but I think I had the right I had the
wrong mindset going into it and then now
as I'm getting older I realize like the
value in
kind of creating your own metrics kind
of like how Jordan does it right yeah
how he just like kind of stacks certain
things in his mind so then he helps him
push him a little bit farther but then
again it's like you realize that having
that competitive mindset is a mindset
that you just have to be because I think
I was so far the opposite way so
thinking with more competitive like more
competitive mindset is I think is
helpful for me dude I hate Cardona
holders
straight up and I and I want to destroy
them and I do destroy them 14 in six
months I'd kill myself yeah but you know
why you don't want to destroy your
competition to the point of death why
because you want something of low
quality out there so people can value
you better yeah for sure so like
to me it makes no sense to monopolize
like
monopolies are actually not that great
because
overall there's going to be someone else
that comes and disrupts you and they'll
they'll eventually win because you
didn't upgrade you because there was no
competition you did you know do anything
to to sharpen your tools you know what's
funny I bet when you guys first started
JK news there were a lot of channels
that viewed you as Rivals yeah other
people try to copy and they just sucked
yeah he's talking about the Fung
brothers
dang I'm just being a writer dude is
David hates him I hate him
you hate you hate everyone David hates
David hates my head
it's just simple I'm just the right I'm
just a writer I read
you feel like they were trying to steal
you guys [__] I don't think so I think
um people have blatantly told us like
hey I'm gonna this this format's cool
other people they came on as a guest
and then all of a sudden you see them
use the same exact format with the with
the news and and then they just couldn't
have an interesting conversation Timmy
did that he owned it he told you guys oh
he did yeah he's like I did that [__]
but like yeah we couldn't do it it was
it was too much work
it wasn't cost effective so I mean yeah
there are groups out there that I mean
we're not we're not Reinventing the
wheel here it's a bunch of people having
a conversation you're Reinventing a
slightly Square bumpy ass week and
outdated that makes the car [__] up
still rolling we invented the flat tire
but I feel like it was such it was such
a first of its kind when you guys
started doing it I could totally see and
I did it still kind of is though I did
see a lot of people like really try to
switch their channels to being more like
that
but I mean podcasts are really cracking
right now yeah and then like you know
there's Roundtable discussions that live
stream for like three hours like you
know there's a lot of different Twitter
spaces that go for [__] 24 hours dude
yeah what the [__] are people doing but
they're there though and then you know
they're doing really good but um I don't
really know so like they used to compare
us to Wong Fu a lot but that's very
different yeah it's really different but
that's when we did shorts the only two
Asians doing like short film or like
sketches or whatever that's why yeah the
thing about early Asian YouTube is we
were all in collaboration with each
other it was a dope error it was so
[__] cool even within the dance world
too like and it's just like man that was
a good time because the pre-monetization
days monetization
but it was it was such a
it was such a like I didn't at least
maybe there was rivalry in other like
small little niche groups right I didn't
feel it you know it felt it felt dope it
felt like let's work together let's do
this let's do that interesting I wonder
how many of those people
like just one-sidedly viewed you guys as
the Target because it was a way to
Aspire
it must have been a lot for sure you
guys have to be like that to somebody do
you guys ever yeah but then there's no
one there that still topped us and we're
still here so you're still here I know
if we don't die soon we have to get
tattoos so okay I know someone the enemy
reveal yourself someone take it please
make your plan I don't want a tattoo
coming up I mean there's I mean we went
on the jumpers jump podcast and there's
like other podcast groups that are that
are pretty interesting gen Z yeah but I
see them as like podcast yeah and they
see the JK as like tribute they always
like big up JK yeah and that's a
difference right it's not rivalry it's
like it's like inspo yeah and it's a
different generation exactly so I feel
like we're not even in direct
competition because they have their own
audience we have our own audience you
know oh you know what might be a
something for you did you ever have a
rival in a writer's room because that
[__] happens a lot all the time but it
was the joke it was always the joke it
was always to get your joke in
like the person wasn't really the thing
for me it was always getting your joke
in there was no one that was trying to
like you could feel them trying to get
their joke in past your joke or
something no because we just had each
other's backs it's very much like JK
like it was like we all are competing
with each other yes
but to get your joke to make the project
funnier to make the whole project yeah
yeah yeah and like that's it made me a
better listener honestly because like I
think going in there I was very rigid
with that my joke my joke my joke I want
to get my joke in right but then it I
became much more of like a I got why it
matters so much to have so many
different voices in the room because did
you feel like you had a mentor in that
room that helped with that or is this I
had a mentored improv that helped me
with that for sure that helped me carry
that mindset into the writer's room or
at least learn from it quickly yeah
because my mentor was his name is
Trenton he was an improviser and he he
just basically told me like why I sucked
at improv and it made me cry
um not into his face it wasn't a [__]
but I went in my truck I went and cried
I was living I was living in San Diego
at the time I was very young I was like
in the truck [__]
like a vampire punching a dress but he
was telling me that he's like you know
you're you're making about you like the
yeah you can't make it about you it's
got It's about your partner it's always
about making your partner look good
right and that was huge for me and you
know you could just be a cocky [__]
right and go no I'm not the problem
solution or whatever that's a gangster
line I was really thankful for that
because it really made me progress to a
different point where because you don't
get anywhere if people don't want to
work with you right like like you really
won't get very far you could get like to
a certain level but you'll never get
very far and so yeah making so people
want to work with me was huge after that
and like I really got the collaborative
Spirit more and yeah I look forward to
it more so to answer your question like
getting the joke through to make the
thing better was always more important
to me than just making it about me or
even getting credit you know like I
remember writing
I mean I wrote like a bunch of [__] that
like nobody even knows I wrote Because
like that's how it works in that land
did you ever have a person when you were
first starting YouTube
did was there a person that was copying
you verbatim every step of the way
because you were you were the first for
a lot of [__] yeah yeah there was but
they didn't get what I was doing really
like I don't and I'm not complimenting
myself I just think that like it's like
JK you guys knew exactly what you were
doing and um like to a degree like you
guys were making it up as you go like we
all were but you guys knew what you were
wanting to do and like what your mission
statement was and I think that a lot of
people when they're copying something
they don't have that heart to it there's
no soul to it that way yeah they're just
observing a successful formula and then
they just do it duplication but they're
like the swap meet bootleg version of it
yeah and people know and people can feel
it and people are really really you know
we give the audience hell sometimes like
or at least the prototypical idea of an
audience person like oh I'm sitting on
the couch I'm drooling I'm watching I'm
consuming content but they really do see
things that's why cameras get up close
right we need a close-up because we need
to see the human expression to be
conveyed easily to the audience and
people are really really smart that and
the lizard brain catches catches all so
I just think they couldn't figure out
what I was doing and even watching like
some of the prank stuff that I watch now
where people go like oh I got into
pranks with you I'm like
don't tell me that dude
because yours was the anti-prank
that is stupid to miss the message and
go I got into pranks too yeah like hey
dude I did the breaking into your house
prank please check it out and like let
me know I just saw this one where they
did an ATM robbery prank and all they
were doing was guys that were pulling
out money from the ATM they came up and
held they went behind and held them oh
my God and then the guy that that was
yeah so he went up and did this right in
a bystander saw and he turned around and
he smacked him in the face and he had a
bloody nose and he was like it was just
a break and it's like
where's the prank you're robbing people
you dumbass what is the prank I don't
understand because to them they don't
know the [__] difference yeah they're
just trying to be Steve Green
prank king that's like me coming up to
someone with a gun on their head and
said give me all your [__] money
right and they're screaming and you're
like
it's all break you [__] don't overreact
and it's funny because how many waves of
resurgence of bad prank two are we gonna
see because it always goes like this
right I feel like it's only bad now like
it's I've been seeing a good YouTube
prank in a while but there's but there's
still very few like like
um people that prank the prank like like
what like what Steve was doing very very
little people know how to capture that
art well that's why it's the best yeah
yeah it was funded it was really fun but
they YouTube hates satire and they told
me so many times
thank you
foreign